[Music]
meet the residents of element City
Air usually has their head in the clouds
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy nothing weird going on here uh
just a little pruning water is always
getting into something
[Music]
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
[Music]
the pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
you've never left firetown sorry buddy
elements don't mix hey plus my dad would
boil you alive why does anyone get to
tell you what you can do in your life
come on
why do they even have these who knows
remember I see a change in you
what her guy you live here it's my mom's
place we got two kids that are swimming
around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes I everyone's asked what I wanted
to do
right this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh
look we're really sorry Splinter some of
the guys wanted to get pizza and I tried
to talk him out of it you ratted us out
hey don't use that word that way I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
this is insane
I want to know everything about you our
data is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
peoples they got to go okay um sort of a
twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dunk
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom rapper F you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
imagine a place
where wishes come true
for your heart's desire can become a
reality
what if I told you that place
you have to do is give your wish
to me
I wish
[Music]
what was that
what
were you doing well do you know doing
that
[Music]
it didn't work when does the magic
happen huh
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low
[Music]
but I can take them on one at a time
this wish to have something more for us
than this
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever wow
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
it's not funny
don't don't do that
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
what okay miles
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy dangerous this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's the guy I gotta do to join
this spider team you can never be part
of this don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999.99
come on go easy on the kid he had a
terrible teacher Peter miles you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
I can't lose one more friend
there's no idea what are you doing
he's telling me how my story is supposed
to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and then I looked at my cool ah let me
guess he died
[Music]
what
what your mother never told you you were
royalty the women in our family have the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now movie you're a princess aggress
the crowd
I think
I am having a panic at that okay Ruby
have it completely totally ordinary day
you got this
[Music]
I feel like a freak out I just want to
be Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
let's see what you're capable of
body armor almost
time to go big
uh we're still on for a tutoring session
later right oh
do what now I mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
bad brother
I think I like the first one better
[Applause]
will you read us a bedtime story okay
three little kittens with fur all
brushed said we can't sleep we feel too
rushed wow this is garbage do you
actually like this illumination the
studio that brought you Despicable Me
The Secret Life of pets
I feel heroic and handsome
a little wet but I still look good the
Grinch
You're a Mean One mister
sing
oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you
minions
[Applause]
and the Super Mario Brothers movie
there's a huge Universe out there
this Christmas illumination brings you a
film for the entire family
here we go tail for the torsion check
Wing deployment
let's fly
migration
We're not gonna make it early Uncle Dan
we're gonna be late for the royal
wedding let's go get married what I mean
let's give Bridget and Crystal married
yeah oh cause that would be weird if we
got married yeah wow
oh boy that was a crazy bachelor party
uh Cloud guy don't feel so good
tiny diamond you make the cutest Little
Flower Boy come on Daddy I'm the cutest
little flower man
we are gathered here today
I'm John Dory branches long lost brother
calling me
you're the guy from Grow Zone we were
just listening to them
but that's all in the past how come you
never told me you had a secret brother
correction used to be my brother
my brothers walked out on me and never
came back Branch we're out of sync we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to go the back
streets
Rich it's time to find the rest of our
brothers and get the band back together
bro we're gonna have the best family
reunion ever rosezone 2.0 Rosa reunion
froze on Here We Grow Again Frozone
where'd they bro I don't know we're
gonna find them
[Music]
random dude on another Musical Adventure
oh hey tiny you see that button right
there oh you mean the button that's
taking every five of them I'll be and
not the prep press it
thank you
[Music]
wow too much hustle is a thing
huh look at that
[Music]
all right that's the car
oh my God okay
not sure if you know who I am but I'm
about to rule the world
wow
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing an identical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're horrible oh I got this no
problem
get it out get it out get it off
there's a huge Universe out there
with a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you broke the rules he went to the above
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans he has to
stop I just want to know more about them
[Music]
poor child I can help you you can't live
in that world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
[Music]
someday I'll be
he's a Healer you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
so it's the last day of the bolza rally
an archieving glorious is
thank you I'm gonna be the champion
I just want to race
[Music]
a silk road rally oh it's gonna be epic
building a trophy case I mean you
haven't even won yet but I will you seem
pretty confident you're gonna win
willing to stick a bet on it you're the
one who's supposed to be going to be
doing the beating of me
fit the idea laughs
[Laughter]
why the long face kid kind of have to
sort of race the Silk Road Rally that
race is no holds bar 200 miles per hour
for four days straight across
unforgiving terrain against the craziest
drivers in the world
I know how am I gonna beat the best
racer in the world alright kid listen
got everything you need but you and me
together
there ain't nothing we can do
whoa okay let's see what you got let's
go
this is crazy
do you see that guy's car if I had a car
like that cars don't win races
[Music]
oh
I'm in way over my head I can help you
but no questions asked you would do that
but why okay there was two questions
right off the line see you tomorrow
[Music]
oh thanks I
you are the most amazingly beautiful
demon I have ever seen
the forest wow
why have you trenched pads here strange
lady offered me a big reward to find a
special lead
in the forest behind the dark Mountain
[Music]
did you find a tree
and where is this peasant loser
[Music]
you could play your music for me do you
realize how illegal this is
[Music]
this human is no different than all the
others he will betray you
incredible
Lucas wasn't the source of life
[Music]
there's only one way to stop this evil
strike Birds
go and never return
[Music]
I love how no matter where you look you
see goodness
but you have made the same mistake I
made once
and the forest alike
fire and hatred Without End
foreign
[Music]
to make contact with outer space as soon
as you arrived the signal started coming
I believe that you are
a human
and it's henna
human antenna why does your status over
I got a dog
[Music]
what's your name my name is Obama oh
crap where are we going now little
darling come on follow me oh no this is
not happening I think it's best if we go
to Wild Splat Walt this is Obama
uh no my name's actually Brittany
Brittany
Walt she crashed with her spaceship and
a man came and took it and now she can't
get home oh my word that's Robert is he
a bad man no no he's not a bad guy but
his brother is we will finally know the
answer does life exist in outer space
and more importantly can it be stuffed
we need to get to the spaceship little
antenna before he does we gotta hurry I
love that kind of enthusiasm let's go
[Music]
I can see the whole world wonderful
I promise you we'll get your spaceship
tomorrow huh
would you like a cup sure thanks maybe
just half a cup
[Music]
you're born here
raised here
the storm is the only World you've ever
known
as a place just off past the Eastern
Ridge
right there dad what are you talking
about you'll see
get out there
little crater
whatever's out there your dad wants you
to see it we've never even been outside
the Dome before
so what's it gonna be we're leaving
tonight are you here he's weird why
Earth so the peculiar you're peculiar
all in favor
let's go steal her over
lockdown 4. three two one
you know the best thing about road trips
everything behind
here it is bottom of the night the wind
up
thank you
[Music]
this guy on Earth isn't really blue yeah
most important thing to remember this is
a bad idea
[Music]
it's about where you're going
meteor shower
run it's about how you get there
the people you get there with Caleb
what's in the crater I don't know
I guess we'll find out you guys go first
you're never quite the same as you were
when you began and you were the best two
days of my life
[Music]
thank you
huh who's there huh
[Music]
I can't believe you're real I'm a tooth
fairy I need your tooth to get home oh
yeah and this is Gwen she's cool my name
is Maxie I lost all my teeth ages ago
huh
trapped in the human world I don't
really fit in back home
fairy needs help you should stay I can't
if a fairy stays in the human world for
too long it becomes a flower forever
bringing her home we have to find that
portal an ancient portal in an old tree
it takes courage I was a portal where
would I hide
now right now no friendship her
transformation has begun
Violetta come on let's search the tree
and family I think Maxie ran away I know
where she went
[Music]
oh
my fairy Troublemaker playing dumb huh
well nobody plays dumber than me wait
until
stop time Monday whether you like it or
not
[Music]
you were flying a little bug did it
I think that's a bug
she is a fairy are you
Peter Pan were you expecting someone
else
Neverland is this everything he dreamed
of I could never dreamed of this
where is this place no rules no schools
no bedtimes and most of all no growing
up are you Wendy
Peter
Captain it's Peter Pop
ever say
his name
[Music]
don't touch my brother
miss me just like old times all your
times are old captain
did you hear that
that is one big
[Applause]
to grow up might just be the biggest
adventure of all
I've always wanted to be a heroine
[Music]
a hero is a human Patty not a little
mouse like you oh you must use our
gratitude it's awesome certainly deserve
I'll give you Southern days to make a
statue of me that as beautiful as my
brothers come on they're all counting on
us
I wonder what it's like going through
rough weather on a boat add more
lightning
feeling a bit seasick don't have my
ceilings yet
[Music]
foreign
happy first day of seventh grade did you
have another math dream yep did you win
yep nice come on here comes the two to
the three and four I'm so excited this
year we have some 12 year olds joining
our high school class who's ready to get
machinated
I actually need some help with something
it's about that msm2 Prime I'll never
know who I am unless I know who he was
your father had a real way with words
wait Dad was a rapper for real what's
his name probably haven't heard of him
he died when I was five
[Music]
hi
wait why are we yelling dad
Seth are you ghost a goat no I'm too old
for an imaginary friend well you're too
young for a midlife crisis but here we
are who is train Patel
that's on me I can't grab why not hip
hop is in your DNA
this methol thinks he's a rapper now
you couldn't school but in the real
world you'll always be a loser
hey truth is bullies are afraid of
dreamers
[Music]
you love math this matters to me this is
inside you
Riding in Cars with high schoolers
do they Vape no matter where we go just
do you do your best that's what's
important
[Music]
people
[Applause]
Benito
beneath the lies the last
Living Dead today my daughter the
Phoenix will choose your future husband
in seven days you shall when the
princess marry we've never even met who
in
God I have to marry a guy who's only
talented riding around in a circle if
anything happens to this ring they will
cut out your tongue and pluck out your
eyes kind of brings new meaning to the
expression Love is Blind
this ring is going
where nobody else can get to him
[Music]
on the other side of this door
lies a doorway to a world of living
mummies
[Music]
attack
this could only be the work of livings
this will be the jewel of my new
exhibition the only way to get it back
is to go to the world of the living
you're not alone you have a team
what ice is this I've never seen
anything like it
[Music]
god of the son God of Life Light our
path please kindly finish your shopping
we have and proceed towards the exit
that way oh
magnificent
there is another special place
up in the Himalayas it's called the
Tiger's Nest I know about that place
[Music]
come come with me come out
come get it
good tiger you took care of me I call
you mukti
[Music]
and they're asking where the mother is
she's gone
like me
so why are you taking it to the Tiger's
Nest the photos he'll do anything to get
that covered
actually the mother though if she's
going to survive
[Music]